we're nearly two weeks away from the
start of hybrid learning for
sixth ninth and twelfth graders in the
clark county school district
but the transition is annoying some
families and causing more questions than
answers
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
is live in the newsroom tonight with the
latest kristin
orko a few issues for families right now
they range from transportation
scheduling to not filling out a new
return
survey concerns as some families remain
uncertain
about their students going back in
buildings
there's just a lot of questions
around secondary frustration from
families
it's just irresponsible of the district
to not be
re-surveying parents universally rebecca
garcia criticizes ccsd
not offering a new hybrid survey for 4th
through 12th graders
the president of the nevada parent
teacher association tells me
some families want to switch their
choice from last year
more public health statistics have
changed the vaccine is now available
and all of us who filled it out in
november aren't getting a chance to
change our response
the decision partly stems from the
district trying to schedule
transportation for the kids who do
choose to come back they need at least a
three week
headway and if we did the whole survey
process again
from my understanding it would delay
kids coming back on campus at least
another week or two
tam lahnert is principal at spring
valley high school he
welcomes the return of students on
campus but knows the hybrid schedule
is not ideal they're only taking two
classes a day for two days a week it's
going to look very different
the hybrid plan shows secondary students
attend class in person twice a day
then leave campus to finish their other
courses remotely
the district allots 40 minutes between
dismissal and the next
class creating a logistics issue for
parents like alandra reynolds
we won't have time to be able to get him
back to make it back to class
a reason why garcia and others
questioned the district
not updating the plan there's just so
many challenges
with them some schools are re-surveying
families to know which option is best
for their students
either full-time distance education or
hybrid learning now the next
group going back are grades six nine and
twelve they're returning on march 22nd
all ccsd employees are going back into
the buildings
next monday reporting live in the
newsroom kristen drummond 8 news now